PRACTICE.
HOLIDAY GETS IT.
SHOT CLOCK AT THREE.
HOLIDAY LOOKS UP, DRIVES, THROWS
IT UP.
NO GOOD!
REBOUND, BOOKER.
SUNS HAVE A TIME-OUT.
DECIDE NOT TO CALL IT.
BOOKER, THE DRIVE.
GETS INSIDE.
LEANS IN.
KNOCKED AWAY AND STOLEN BY
HOLIDAY.
PHOENIX HAS TO FOUL.
AND ANTETOKOUNMPO THROWS IT
DOWN!
AND A FOUL.
GIANNIS ON THE ALLEY-OOP.
WHAT A TURNAROUND!
A CHANCE TO TAKE THE LEAD AND
THE TURNOVER HAS THE BUCKS NOW
UP BY THREE AND A FREE THROW
COMING UP.
>> Mark: WHAT A PLAY BY JRUE
HOLIDAY.
GETS INTO THE PICTURE, COMES UP
WITH THE STRIP.
TURNING THE BASKETBALL OVER AND
THEN OFF TO THE RACES.
COULD HAVE HELD IT OUT.
INSTEAD, MADE THE RIGHT READ.
THROWS IT UP WHERE ONLY GIANNIS
CAN CATCH IT.
FINISHES IT WITH THE CONTACT.
>> Mike: BAD DECISION TO FOUL,
BECAUSE THIS WOULD MAKE IT A
FOUR-POINT GAME WITH 13.5
REMAINING.
PHOENIX STILL HAS A TIME-OUT.
CRITICAL FREE THROW FOR GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
MISSED IT.
FIGHT FOR THE REBOUND.
TIPPED AND TAKEN BY MIDDLETON,
AND THEY HAVE TO FOUL MIDDLETON
WITH 9.8 REMAINING.
THEY COULDN'T SECURE THE
DEFENSIVE REBOUND.
>> Jeff: HE MISSED SO BAD THAT
IT BECAME DIFFICULT TO GET THE
DEFENSIVE REBOUND.